messieurs bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur arte france comment est-ce
que vous réagissez aux propos que l'on
vient d'entendre ceux du sénateur et
l'air stéphane le rudulier qui était au
micro des stèles farjat l'instant
patrick bourdillon où il n'y a pas de
réaction particulière est simplement une
question qui se pose en matière en tout
cas législation puisque si j'étais très
très clair en tout cas sur sa position
vis-à-vis la vaccination nous sommes
pour la vaccination nous sommes opposés
à l'obligation vaccinale donc avril
après avoir un débat qui est un débat
soit un débat de loi soit soins débâcle
politique et sur les décisions qui sont
prises d'un côté par le sénat a adopté
par l'assemblée nationale nous ne sommes
pas cette analyse la solution d'analysé
en tout cas dans la population
hospitalière des conséquences qu'à
l'obligation vaccinale et surtout des
conséquences que ça dans la population
notamment en matière de l'impossibilité
de pouvoir agir de façon libre de
pouvoir circuler de façon libre sur
cette question d'ailleurs il n'y a pas
de questions spécifiques de la cgt en
matière légale si je n'ai pas de notre
compétence n'est pas dans notre domaine
en tout cas de réaction votre réaction à
voir et à écouter
indiqué le sénateur
malheureusement et vous savez c'est
l'assemblée nationale qui aura le
dernier mot en la matière et ce qui va
se passer certainement c'est que le
texte sera voté pratiquement dans les
mêmes conditions que le projet qui a été
présenté au parlement c'est ce qui est
très frustrant et surtout très
inquiétants parce que effectivement
cette imposition du bass vaccinale est
un recul absolument
très important des libertés
fondamentales dans notre pays on va
créer effectivement deux catégories de
citoyens
les longues vacciner et les vaccinés et
ont fait fi intégralement du libre choix
de la vaccination et du droit tout
simplement de disposer de son corps en
mai certains politiques notamment ceux
issus de la majorité soutiennent que
faire vacciner tout le monde et -
liberty moins liberticide que de laisser
circuler le virus qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
mais effectivement
on vous en
voulez peut-être commencer la réponse on
n'a pas entendu ce que vous venez de
dire un problème de communication
je vous disais effectivement que à mon
sens on peut venir vous dire ce qu'on
veut le fait est que l'on impose une
vaccination par le biais de ce pass
vaccinale et cette imposition de
vaccination est naturellement
liberticide à partir du moment où on
impose quelque chose aux gens
contre leur gré pour certains c'est que
effectivement on limite la liberté
de fait patrick bourdet dans votre votre
position ah non sélectionnés c'est une
saisine conduire une remarque qui est
une quête une réponse totalement
légaliste nous à la cgt on envisage se
tenait deux façons différentes en disant
que la loi par essence la loi
liberticide puisqu'elle va limiter la
liberté leaders locaux en scène des
autres donc par essence à lois
liberticides derrière les vraies
questions qui se posent sont plutôt des
questions qui sont des questions
politiques et surtout des questions
d'organisation du système de santé en
france puisqu'elle n'arrivait à obliger
la vaccination du temps n'est pas en
capacité de pouvoir gérer derrière soi à
l'affût de passer aux hôpitaux soit de
pouvoir gérer ce qui a été un travail en
tout cas qu'il était nécessaire de
prévention en amont ou un travail et
pouvoir prendre en charge ne serait ce
qu'à domicile des patients de façon
correcte c'est plutôt à ce niveau là pas
question se pose être obligé d'en
arriver à la loi pour contraindre une
solution qui va être toute façon un
pis-aller dans le c c'est derrière on
aveu de faiblesse et surtout un aveu
d'échec nos gouvernements qui n'a pas su
en tout cas mettre en oeuvre une
stratégie politique claire notamment en
matière d'organisation de santé et
surtout en matière de pouvoir répondre
aux nécessités aux besoins des
populations donc là effectivement nous
assisterons constat d'échec c'est ça
veut dire patrick bourdillon qu'on est
en train de débattre sur quelque chose
qui ne devrait pas avoir lieu parce que
l'on sait aujourd'hui 160 mille français
voient l'or pas sanitaire être validé
faute de rappel vaccinal met donc au
sujet du post vaccinales la classe
politique ces chars pour bien de le voir
encore aujourd'hui mais si on n'avait
pas supprimé 5000 700 lits en 2020
malgré l'épidémie de covin est-ce qu'on
en serait là aujourd'hui parce qu'on est
en train de débattre de guéguerre
administrative
légale alors que le problème est
peut-être plus profond non et peut-être
plus profond mais c'est surtout qu'ils
ne sont pas des deuxièmes vous comme moi
donc on sait pas du tout ce qui sera
devenu si on n'avait pas supprimé ces 5
min on sait de soissons qui sera d'une
façon claire c'est qu'on aurait pu
organiser la santé et l'offre de soins
de façon plus large pour répondre aux
besoins des populations dans les
territoires
mais c'est pas les 5000 y supprimer en
devises mais qui nous pose problème son
ami d'avant laisse évidemment il est
soumis depuis 20 ans donc c'est tron est
donc un structurelles donc ça
c'est pas structurel les limouxins
pathologique apparaissent au delà de la
simple réponse qui est une réponse de
d'organisation des soins et des
possibilités de prendre en charge des
patients je voulais dit sa prime de
prévention de quelle façon à ce qu en
france on n'a pas organisé y compris la
recherche pourra répondre de façon très
rapide à des problématiques sont des
pragmatiques d'apparition et d'émergence
de nouvelles pathologies on le voit les
mutations du virus en tout cas on sait
qu hamid en situation de pouvoir
investir y compris dans la recherche
publique et le grand chu ont été mis en
systèmes de production des systèmes de
fonctionnement sur lesquels ce qui était
rentable d'être produit et on le voit
c'est un système où la rentabilité à
court terme a prévalu sur la cécité de
voir à long terme on paye cash ce qui
est ce qui s'est passé depuis un certain
nombre d'années et on paye cash ce que
le gouvernement en place actuellement a
accéléré depuis qu'il est là
quand m vous êtes à l'origine de la
suspension du pass sanitaires dans les
centres commerciaux dans les yvelines
selon la présidente de la commission des
lois à l'assemblée nationale il ya le
brunch yvel le texte donc sur ce pass
vaccinale pourrait être
mise en place
à la fin de la semaine prochaine qu'est
ce que ça impliquerait pour les
commerçants et l'activité économique
d'une façon générale est-ce que vous
allez vous battre une nouvelle fois pour
faire en sorte que ce post vaccinales
soit supprimé comme vous l'avez fait le
pas de sanitaires
naturellement il est hors de question
que l'on laisse
cette loi être mise en place sans qu'il
y ait de batailles juridiques à
l'encontre de ce projet qui est mis en
place un moment moi la question que je
me pose est la suivante c'est que vous
savez il est toujours très facile de
céder des libertés au profit d'un peu de
sécurité mais quand il s'agit par la
suite de pouvoir récupérer ses libertés
c'était autrement plus compliqué et là
c'est ce qui va se passer parce que à
partir du moment où vous avez imposé ce
que les les parlementaires les
républicains notamment les sénateurs en
un amendement pour faire en sorte que le
pass vaccinale soit supprimée pour à
partir du moment où qui nous dira pas
dans le temps notamment en termes
d'hospitalisation dès qu'on passe en
dessous des dix mille on supprime se
passe vaccinale oui c'est ce qui est
d'ailleurs prévu actuellement pour le
parent sanitaires dans les centres
commerciaux mais en attendant on aura
toujours cette épée de damoclès
au-dessus de la tête et puis on nous
dira on pourra très bien de dire un
moment ou un autre ont rétabli le pass
vaccinale est de toute façon il faut se
parler clairement même si le conseil
d'état dans un avis de juillet
2021 avait indiqué que le pas salutaire
ou le pass vaccinale maintenant ne doit
pas avoir pour objectif d'inciter les
gens la vaccination la réalité c'est ça
c'est que le bât sanitaires et
maintenant le pass vaccinale à courre
seul et unique objet d'obliger et
d'inciter à minima les gens à se faire
vacciner et ça c'est totalement
contraire à toutes les règles
fondamentales auxquelles notre pays est
soumis à votre réaction patrick bourdy
oui mais moi je peux être encore un peu
plus loin ce qu'il faut il faut
réellement se poser se poser la question
de quelle façon à ce que la loi sert à
masquer un certain nombre de choses
quand la loi sert à masquer l'indigence
politique et je prenais une préparation
d'un pays affronte et je voulais dire
les berges de nouveaux virus que ce sera
le cas dans les prochaines années mais
si on se met dans la situation de le
dire car la contrainte telle qu'elle est
posée est une contrainte qui sert au
bien du peuple moi je m'interroge et on
s'interroge surtout à savoir quel
incident a nécessité un moment de mettre
la loi comme élément central en tout cas
pour atteindre l'objectif la loi pour
moi ce n'est pas l'élément central le
premier élément central qui doit être
remplacé celui de proposer des
situations qui permettent à chacun aux
uns comme aux autres d'être prises en
charge c'est la première démarche est
celle là l'est dans une logique de
prévention je rappelle qu'on accord sur
un gouvernement qui a détruit la
médecine qui la médecine du travail la
médecine préventive donc quand les
camions démarche sur ce sujet là en tout
cas n'est pas abordée il sait pas la loi
qui va arriver à le cacher et derrière
c'est de quelle façon à ce que ce mais
surtout en situation se demander de
quelle façon est ce qu'on peut avoir les
médicaments nécessaires certes et on
doit en tout cas la logique marchande
qu'il posait au niveau de l'accès mais
aussi au niveau des futurs traitements
et une logique qui nous laisse assez
interpellative et quand on voit le prix
de chaque injection en tout cas de
vaccins qui proposait la population
combien c'est payé par la sécurité
sociale on peut rester aussi
interrogatifs et se demander de quelle
façon nous demandons la cgt la
libéralisation ils sont la liberté des
brevets et cet élément en tout cas n'a
pas été entendu n'a pas été prise en
compte et cet élément de contrainte qui
suffit pas vaccinale juba sanitaire peu
importe comment l'appel en tout cas
c'est pas quelque chose qui solutionnera
la pandémie c'est pas quelque chose qui
permettra au pays d'en sortir pour le c
est par contre c'est quelque chose qui
effectivement peut laisser des traces
politique à la cgt on ne commente pas
jolie fille jade y est ce que ce n'est
pas un sujet en tout cas que notre
ressort nous ce que nous voyons c'est
qu'on a un système hospitalier et un
système de santé en france qu'un train
se délabrer qui en train de craquer qui
est au bord de l'implosion et que tout
ce qu'on pousse qu'on dit tout ce qu'on
a répété depuis 7h modane est en train
de se produire donc maintenant ce n'est
pas parce quand même posé la vaccination
pour la pêche rose fluo système
hospitalier de craquer il est en train
de craquer et c'est pas parce qu'on va
me poser un certain nombre de lois
liberticides à la population que les
choses au mieux aller ça on éclaire pas
encore sonné vous avez dit quand quand
l'épidémie s'arrêteront c'est qu'il y a
a été évoqué à plusieurs reprises le mot
le terme en des milk comme quoi la
pandémie serait peut-être fini qu'on
partirait sur une endémie si c'est le
tien par rapport aux passes vaccinale
est ce qu'il aura encore lieu d'être
ben ont normalement il devrait pas avoir
lieu d'être mais qui va pouvoir vérifier
ce genre de choses la question est la
suivante on peut à partir du moment où
on était capable d'accepter quand même
l'imposition d'un pass vaccinale à
l'ensemble d'une population
moi je pose la question aujourd'hui
quelle sera la prochaine étape quelle
est la prochaine loi liberticide
effectivement qui sera votée dans ce
pays et au fur et à mesure on va lâcher
des droits dont on a luz âge depuis des
décennies voire des siècles il faut
quand même se dire que là on nous impose
une règle de contrôle je dirais d'un
état de santé pour avoir à effectuer des
choses qui ce qui était il ya quelques
il ya quelques mois totalement naturelle
allait prendre un café aller dans un
restaurant rentrer dans un centre
commercial tout ça c'est un changement
de société on assiste à un changement de
société et
dieu seul sait finalement si on arrivera
un jour à revenir à la société de vente
et pour terminer moi ce que je veux vous
dire c'est que cette situation crée un
problème qui peut même être de l'ordre
finalement la psychologie parce que ce
qui se passe c'est que on crée on donne
à certaines personnes un droit que
d'autres n'ont pas c'est à dire aux
personnes vaccinées qui ont plus de
droits que les personnes non vaccinées
qu'est-ce qu'on va expliquer à ces gens
là une fois que l'épidémie sera passée
on va leur dire bah finalement vous êtes
vacciné merci voit pas salutaire bon
vous en avez plus besoin et pour
redonner au même niveau que les
personnes qui ne sont pas vaccinés vous
pensez que cela est possible moi ça me
paraît le le fait de revenir en arrière
me paraît aujourd'hui totalement
impossible on est dans une fuite en
avant et on a cet effet cliquet qui nous
empêche qui va nous empêcher de revenir
à notre videmment voilà moi le sens de
mes observations patrick bordés on vous
aviez
fête des mascottes de tête vous voulez
réagir
n'a pas forcément de même abordé chose
la baule abord légal effectivement à sa
propre vision des choses qui nous sommes
tout à fait cohérente c'est une première
pour le match les gars derrière moi je
reviendrai plus tôt sur notre
problématique essais de fonctionnement
notre système de santé en france et
notamment plus largement ce qu'ils font
en tout cas fonder la sécurité sociale
et la volonté de pouvoir un moment
soigner l'ensemble de la population on
est sûrs en est sûrement démarche est
novatrice en tout cas en matière la
pression de politique et c'est de dire
la responsabilité des abus comme acte
avant d'être malade c'est la vôtre donc
est-ce que d'eux mêmes nous allons
soigner des infarctus du myocarde
patients soignés à fumer est-ce que nous
allons demain on va soigner les années
c'est parce que bastien abus d'alcool
est-ce qu'on va demander des
antériorités en tout cas de règles de
vie et d'hygiène de vie dans la logique
dans ton scène des passions c'est pas
notre amour des choses de ce qui est de
ce qu'est le souhait parce que
l'organisation des soins sur tout ce que
la politique de santé la petite santé en
tout cas nous concernant nous sommes
soignants c'est de se dire que nous
acceptons et nous accueillir l'ensemble
des malades quels que soient leur
antériorité et là on est sur une logique
on va fermer la porte et l'accident soit
des magasins certes mais pourquoi pas à
l'hôpital à des patients parce qu'il
refusait un moment d'avoir un geste
dessous et étrangers ce qui est imposé
par la loi et ça nous moralement ça nous
pose un problème éthique mans bien sûr
ce n'est pas du tout jouable est aussi
que les médecins ne joueront pas ce jeu
là mais derrière tout ça et comme une
volonté politique de transformer la
société oui notamment sur la mort ce qui
est la prise en compte des souhaits et
surtout de remboursement des souhaits
vous rappelle que par exemple en
angleterre au royaume uni on ne sommes
plus des patients qui n'ont plus
l'assurance qui leur permet de couvrir
les cancers donc ça ça pose quand même
des questions qui concernent pour les
maladies non remboursés m'a dit qu'ils
sont uniquement à quasiment 100%
guérissable donc on est quand même sur
une logique de transformation de
l'appréhension de ce qu'ils le
souhaitent en tant que telle il nous
interroge on sait qu'on fait pas de
commentaire la loi mais qui perd contre
nous et c'est vraiment un goût amer
merci à vous d'avoir répondu à nos
questions patrick bourdillon je rappelle
que vous êtes secrétaire fédéral cgt
santé était raccord à l'item vous êtes
avocats à l'origine notamment de la
suspension du pass sanitaires dans les
centres commerciaux dans le le
département des yvelines